Okay,
we are back live. Hello.
I got a little bit more uh work in me, I
think, tonight. Just a little bit.
the backward kernel is actually going to
be faster than the forward kernel, isn't
it?
Uh, yeah. Where's the buffer?
I normally do buffers.
This will just be
Brad
out.
And then this is in
and warm buff
like this, right?
Okay.
So
do
float in the norm. Um,
Uh, it's actually really easy from here,
isn't it?
out times
inverse norm. I think this is literally
it, right?
I believe it actually is because yeah,
the only thing that's difficult about
this is this reduction up top, right?
So then actually we can do
can't we just launch the backward
kernel?
We can totally just launch the uh the
black the backward kernel differently,
right?
Oh, okay. So then this is
form idx idx divided by
uh h I believe
the percent h
Oh, in Python. I don't know, man.
All my best uh like beginner stuff is on
Twitter.
Wait, you need grad with respect to the
weights and grad with respect to
This is grad
x
grad weight right.
So this is grad
uh grad with respect to the weight
Well, I'm just implementing this stuff
totally wrong, aren't I? I'm like
forgetting that it has a weight.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay, we'll figure this out
then.
Yeah, my eye.
Yeah. So, it has to be times weight.
Do you still publish papers? No, but I
write blog posts and all my stuff's open
source.
I did just publish um the last well the
last planned paper at the very least is
uh Puffer Lib 2 is in RLC.
I need to put that up on the website
because it got an award. But
anyways,
what is wrong with this
base?
There. No base.
Base
plus H.
What's the uh the LSP like show
whatever
that later?
Okay, let's actually do this correctly.
So
what's the gradient of this?
Uh gradient of this with respect to w is
just this whole quantity, right?
Just norm
this
And then gradient with respect to
with respect to this is
double check something. I think it's
like two.
Uh, but it's probably not actually
I see
it does have an epsilon.
I guess. Yeah, that is actually a
non-trivial gradient. I forgot.
Don't use AI for coding. As little as I
can, man.
Every [ __ ] time I regret it.
And here it's like I'd rather just ask
it for the math and ask it for the code.
But then I don't even trust it to do the
math.
Dude, I It's literally a meme. Like I
had some other guy tell me, "Oh, just
try Claude or whatever." I type the same
[ __ ] in and you like They're all just
dumb. All right. They're all stupid.
Let me let me at least check this
manually. This is epsilon.
Okay, this is the correct form.
Oh, okay. Okay, so this was defined to
be the RMS. Cool.
Gradient of a single output element
if I equals J.
Huh?
Oh, do you actually get cross terms
here? You do, don't you?
on reasoning version. I've tried both.
They all suck. And also, this is just
4.1 that like this is just how they have
it by like set up with 41.
You do actually get cross terms here,
don't you?
Yeah, I totally forgot about that,
right? Because normally you don't have
operations that do this.
Yeah. Okay. So
let's check this first. So this is
the summation
uh it comes from the it comes from the
norm right like the fact that you're
yeah you're dividing by the sum of the
other elements.
X I
single element.
I I don't have to do math all that
often. It's like give me a moment here.
All right, let me remember how the hell
this works.
Okay, so it just it went through this op
for some reason.
Yeah, it's just not showing where it got
this. Let me see. So, RMS of X.5
Yeah, I literally do not remember how to
do this.
Yeah, cuz I have to write out. It's kind
of crazy, but literally the RMS norm
operation, which should take no time. Um
yeah, that one operation
is
taking like 25% overhead.
I suppose I can try this gradient to see
if this gradient is correct because I
can test
We're going to Let's try this one and
we'll assume that this is correct for
now. Let's get this to actually compile
because the grad with respect to weight
is just it's trivial, right? It's just
this.
So then this one is actually going to be
uh and actually want the weight
flow w
Uh. Oh, and you need the input buffer as
well here, don't you?
Yeah, you need the input buffer.
A buff. S buff.
Oh, yeah. I just don't have it in here.
Cool.
I'm not really using tags. Um,
this is so this is Super Maven, which
I'd be very happy to keep using, but uh
Cursor being the dog [ __ ] company that
they are.
they said that they were like getting
rid of it. Unless they stopped unless
they canled that suggestion.
I mean, unless they canled the closure.
If so, major props. Oh, nope.
Free autocomplete inference for existing
companies customers for the foreseeable
future. Wait, what?
Uh,
did I like miss this whole thing?
So, I guess I get to keep using my
autocomplete. Yay.
Do you need to code the gradient
manually for the kernels?
I need to code the gradient for the
kernels manually because PyTorch is too
damn slow. That is what we're doing.
This is ultra high performance RL
optimization.
Uh I I thought you have like trained
Bert. No. Oh,
thank you.
ice cream delivery.
[laughter]
Apparently, my family went to Dairy
Queen while I was here coding.
I mean, it would be awesome to just have
a local Super Maven. That'd be great.
I'd also love to know what the model
architecture is.
I actually had forgotten that this was
going to have cross terms. I thought
this was going to be like a super
trivial operation.
We'll get this implemented and checked
hopefully tonight.
Does anybody know if this is correct?
This can't be that uncommon of an
operation.
I wonder if that was in part due to my
uh
my message
cuz I like [ __ ] them out a whole bunch.
I remember.
Does bitching on the internet actually
work?
I mean, this post didn't even get very
much. Um,
yeah, this post barely even got any
attention. Maybe one of them saw it. Oh,
no. You know, it was probably this one.
It was probably Ironclad.
literally the only usable the only
usable AI plugin.
So I think then the only thing is we can
test this pretty easily and actually
it's pretty quick to get a a gradient
check on this.
I don't even think there's anything that
can be numerically weird here either. So
then the only thing that's going to be a
little tough with this, there's one
thing I don't know how to do. Um, fun
fact, I never learned CUDA. I kind of
just started writing it.
I just sort of went to see that runs on
your GPU. How hard can that be? Well,
there is some extras to do block
reductions and such. And when you do
operations that require accumulations
like this, you have to do block
reductions. So
I'm going to finish this ice cream. I
will answer any random RL questions in
the process and then we're going to
implement the rest of this kernel and uh
we will see
whether I can at least get a working
version of this. I can time it and then
I can see whether it needs block
reduction to actually be fast.
I think it will need block reduction.
I'm not positive, though.
I mean, it's such a tiny kernel, right?
It's almost like impressive how slow
torch is.
It takes the same amount of time to do
the freaking RMS norm as it spends in
Matt Mole.
Welcome geography.
So, that makes no sense, right? Like
literally
this was the profile from before. While
I'm eating this, take a look at this.
Okay,
look how ridiculous this is. Okay, not
the same amount of time, but still look
96 seconds in here.
And I think this was without RMS norm.
It was like 80 seconds at some point in
in mole.
The easier one to see
is it went from 410 ms uh to 540 ms with
RMS norm. So like you know 25% overhead
of the entire entire CUDA time just for
an RMS norm
crazy crazy unoptimized.
I'm trying to think what it even is
possible. It's probably just PyTorch
doesn't bother to do a block reduce,
right?
That's what I would imagine
because I don't know how else you make
it that slow.
So, if I implement this kernel and the
naive version is about the same speed as
the PyTorch one, then I'll know that's
how they did it.
That would actually be kind of funny
because that would mean that my
absolutely newbie level of, you know,
CUDA engine that I'm doing here already
matches the PyTorch back end for this
OP.
Wouldn't be surprising.
I mean the thing is in their mind right
this op is like never the bottleneck
but you shouldn't be writing your
generic tensor processing framework
assuming nobody's ever going to train
networks that are smaller than hundreds
of millions of parameters or whatever
right
torch has been around for long enough as
well that like people were definitely
training way smaller models when it was
when in its infancy
and some out was just always slow.
Look at this in the meantime. See if um
if this makes sense.
You have to sum up. How is it that you
do this when they're cross? You have to
sum up the um the cross terms, right?
gain through the weight RMS without the
weight has gradient well known
one over r minus gxg okay that looks
closer right that's like something I
would believe
substitute x
hat = x / R that simplifies to that.
so provided this gradient is actually
correct, this should not be that bad. If
this gradient is wrong, then I'm going
to have a pain in the ass attempting to
do basic calculus and failing for an
hour most likely.
We got like 15 people watching now. Come
on. Anybody know? Somebody at least has
got to be
fairly recent
on Cal. If you asked me when I was 18, I
could have done this no problem.
I mean, if you go check, I say take
CS231N in my guide, right? If you do
231N, you'll do this.
This is like marginally harder than
high
school calculus.
circle dot symbol. It's just elementwise
multiplication, dude.
Had a hard product. Just element-wise
mult.
If you don't want to see that symbol,
you just write the grad with respect to
x i.
So if you just did PL um partial L
partial X subi then it would be WI times
GI XI WI GI over this is the RMS norm
and then this is the RMS norm cubed and
this is XI
like nowhere near as fancy and then if
you do that then it's like
I mean that really is just high school
calc. Now, the only thing which is the
thing that I totally forgot about that
doesn't come up very often because it
only happens when you have ops that are
like not elementwise like this. When you
have summations and things that like
this um you get these cross terms
because you have to take the partial
right with respect where is it
partial yeah so partial yi with respect
to xj if i equals j that is the single
single variable case
um but you also get derivatives of each
term with respect to the other terms you
end up with these cross terms terms.
If I was looking at this like where the
heck did the cube term come from? So
that's where the cube term
probably this
I'd expect the whole this whole thing
comes from it. Maybe not. Maybe there's
something factored out, but
I think probably that
Oh, no. There is one other term.
Yeah, there is one other term that gets
grouped. That looks like
W over this minus. Yeah. Okay. So,
there's All right. It's a little more
complicated than I expected. Whatever.
This is what happens when you don't do
derivatives for 10 years.
Funny enough though, like the one course
that actually has some math ends up
being the one piece of math that's
actually useful.
Cuz if you know this stuff, right, like
this is honestly the hardest part about
writing your own kernels
So, you know, it's the combination of
you're writing low-level errorprone code
and there's also some like kind of real
math involved.
A math any like math person will tell
you that this is basic [ __ ] But
I mostly write code. So, not so basic
when you haven't done it in a while.
I mean just basic stuff like I can't
even if this were a single variable
right I can't take the gradient of this
quickly by looking at it. It's like
square root ah it's like 0.5 time 10
times wait.5
the power of negative.5 of what do I do
with this epsilon in here does it stay I
forget and then this is this gets
multiplied and then this is what the
heck is this this is
two norm so this is another square root
so this gets another inner p like I
can't take the gradient of that looking
at it I don't
that one. If you'd asked me when I was
16, I could do that.
Oh well, I'll go do a little refresher
at some point if I end up doing a ton of
kernels, but I think we're only going to
end up with a handful of them for this
release.
And a lot more of the effort is is going
to go into the optimization of Perf.
All right, let's get started. Chain
roll. Yeah, I know it's the chain rule,
my guy. The whole freaking like that is
the entirety of back propagation is the
chain roll. That doesn't mean I remember
how to apply it to individual specific
ops.
All right,
let's get cranking.
X
times.
Yeah, that's the funny thing, right?
It's like
a lot of the math that you end up
actually needing and is useful is
relatively simple math.
Okay. So now let's figure out
there are like 10 dot product notations.
There are zero dotproduct notations
here.
What?
Well, excuse me for thinking you were
talking to me on my stream.
out.
No, not grad out.
Grad X.
Good. I haven't read it yet. It looks
insane, which is cool to see that
Forester is not like uh just going with
the crowd.
Math stats to understand ML models.
Well, you sure as hell don't need stats.
You need your pick of stats in linear
algebra.
You can kind of write everything one way
or the other.
Yes, dude. Literally, the RMS norm op
alone is causing 25% overhead. I'm not
joking.
I have a feeling that they I'm going to
see this. I'm going to time this versus
their implementation. I think what's
going to happen is I'm gonna match the
speed of their implementation with this
because they didn't do a block reduce.
I think they just did like, you know,
one thread over the entire hidden dim.
Oh, that multinnomial BS is getting like
crushed. I'm not dealing with that [ __ ]
Like, we're writing a kernel for that
too, I'm sure.
Speaking of which, I just dealt with a
bug with that implementation that you
wrote yesterday. Ah,
that thing propagates nans in a really
weird way.
What did you do? Uh, if you get nans as
inputs in your thing, it will sample
invalid actions. So, it turns out this
was the thing that was causing invalid
actions whenever people were getting
weird runs.
Part of that implementation was removing
all of torches safety checks for speed.
Uhhuh.
you don't need to have nan checks
everywhere, but there do need to be
checks to make sure that you do not
crash the execution of the program if
you get nans.
And uh that one can crash the execution
of the program when you get nans.
Your program is bad and should feel bad.
Uhhuh.
So like all of ML then
how much ML does is LSTM necessary?
Yes. That's not very much ML. That's
like one course, dude.
And LSTM might not be necessary very
soon because we just got soda without an
LSTM.
Holy, look at that. 8.9
which is what we're writing kernels for
now.
A fast mining group.
Don't confuse DRL with RL. Everybody
means deep RL.
Yeah, Mingru works. Mingru is a [ __ ]
though because it's only useful if you
have kernels.
Like you need kernels to make it useful.
Well, it can be way faster than an LSTM
with kernels, but if you just implement
it in torch, like you're going to spend
all your time in this stupid scan
operation.
Uh to solve neural MMO 100% probably
Puffer 5
Yeah. And I couldn't find any decent
kernels for it either. Like it took me
probably 3 days uh of fiddling with
these stupid kernels to get this to
work.
Uh no, we do not want
this is going to be B times
uh t total
because you cannot parallelize you can't
parallelize this.
Yes, exactly. You have to calculate the
derivatives by hand. That's why it
sucks.
So we do grid size.
Grid size
block size like this.
This is Oops.
I'm form
Oh, really? You think so?
Go ahead and try it. Tell me how much
fun it is.
And then when the LLM that you're not
using works and some other [ __ ]
recommends you try a different LLM, go
try that one and see how much fun you
have when that one also doesn't work and
none of them work for 6 hours straight.
And then eventually you just have to
figure out how to do it your damn self.
The LMS are [ __ ] I'm allowed to say
that.
Nope.
The correct thing is in fact that the
LMS are simply [ __ ] and the people who
think otherwise are getting replaced
very soon because they didn't do
anything thinking to begin with.
I'm writing kernels. This is obviously
going to be slow.
It's a combination of very high
precision, but also like there's a ton
of boiler plate
that you just can't get away from cuz
cuda.
I hate boiler plate, but what do you
want me to do?
we write the module.
Oh yeah, this is a great time to mention
for folks here because we have a lot of
folks on at the moment. Um, if you're
interested in my work, I stream all my
dev. I build the fastest open source
reinforcement learning library.
Puffer.ai. Demos that run live in your
browser. Feed the puff for a star helps
me a ton. Uh, everybody's on Discord if
you want to get involved with dev. A lot
of it's much easier than this. And you
can follow me on X for all my research
and educational content. Back to dev.
Somebody's watching me on a flight.
That's funny.
[laughter]
That is funny.
When you have to do template for every
argument. I'm deleting these templates,
my guy. I am straight up deleting all
the templates when I'm done with this.
We're going to support one type and
everybody else can [ __ ] off.
I'd like some CUDA practice. Ooh,
what kernels do I need written?
Well, if you would like to figure out
why um cuz I'm not going to get to this
one for several days, man. Um
loss.
All right. So, this kernel here, I have
this PO fused loss function. It fuses
the entire PO loss function.
It passes numericals pretty well, but it
crashes training.
So if you can figure out why it's
numerically unstable,
that is uh that is kind of the core of
the what I found lately actually like
getting the kernels to pass numerical
tall not that hard. Getting the kernels
to be numerically stable very hard.
First time watching Loving the Hen Gym.
Thank you.
What does crash mean?
When I do if I run this
I have a version of this basically like
you can use I'll make sure it's clean by
tonight. Um but yeah, you can just like
train breakout in with the C version
here in 40 and it works. Uh but when I
use the fused PO loss, it doesn't work
even though it passes.
I have this uh this grad test and like
you can go enable grad test for whatever
and it looks like the gradients are good
but then it doesn't train
bounty time. Yeah. Yeah. I tried FP64.
I FP64 to everything actually as a
default and then I just got the fuse
kernel back to FP32 stable today for um
for the uh parallel scan operation.
How do you test if it's stable? It just
has to train. There's no other way to
test stability other than it does it
train.
All right. So, what we want to do now is
this operation.
I'm just going to copy this whole thing.
This is how much boiler plate there is
for reference with um
UDA work because you need the colonel,
you need the launch, and then you need
the torch binding is a pain in the ass.
Hello from Jason on flight. Oh, is that
you? Hello.
That's funny.
I'm surprised the Wi-Fi uh works for
live streams. You got Starlink on there.
Autograd context.
Do we need context? I don't think we
need
I don't think we need a context
variable, right? Oh, no. You do need a
context. That's default. Yeah,
BCC,
you're free to try it.
Uh, the other thing I really like about
putting things into single kernels, it
makes profiling much easier because it
takes the time from like all the little
individual ops that are annoying and it
just puts them in your custom kernel.
And yeah, you could figure out how to
group things or whatever, but like it's
so much easier to just see like time
spent in your small number of custom
kernels.
Way easier to optimize.
Uh, right. So, this is where we
needsight
Python profiler.
No, I did not see that. I've just been
using torch profile.
Okay. Okay. So, this is going to take
X
and weight.
Does it need weight?
Wait, how do I how do I handle stuff
with a weight?
Do I have any kernels with learnable
weights?
Output is going to be
same device and type. That's correct.
And we need a buffer,
right?
What was the buffer called?
Inorm buff.
and now we actually need to go double
check the
arguments.
Uh this has no epsilon at the moment.
We should add that
before we forget
outdata pointer morm
x and weight
double epsilon.
Right. So we're going to just pass
epsilon as well. Yeah.
Do else if
that can autocomplete
everything. Yep.
Fine.
Then we can just that else we don't
support it.
Cool.
So next
save for backward.
Uh right.
So all you need to save for the backward
pass.
So you'd save X, right?
And you'll save
in norm.
And we have the output pool.
Next, we need to get the backwards pass.
Um, we know what these first bits are
going to be. Let's fill this in.
X weight
out and in norm
get grad outputs
dot contiguous
D type
BT and H
the sizes is.
And then we need
auto grad x.
Auto red weight.
how I specified the launch args here.
So RMS I know that I did the exact same
args for the backward and for the launch
look like this.
And this just has to be pass grad x
wait
uh grad out
gra out and in nororm
x
and then where is it? static
cast, right? Uh we're going to add
epsilon
B. Cool. And I have to remember to add
epsilon before I mess this up.
Uh and this is not launch scan anymore.
This is launch arm as norm.
And let's just make sure this is line by
line the same.
See, it still tries to mess you up
form.
Okay.
Have you ever tried writing tests? Yes,
dude. I have those.
It turns out there are things that you
cannot test. There are many many layers
to CUDA health.
Uh and then we need
grad log cos grad log values. So I don't
actually know how this is going to work
because it's a learnable param.
We'll try like this.
Let's go add this epsilon in before I
forget.
Oh yeah, save for backward. Let's just
add eps.
I I think one of these casts is free,
but whatever.
We'll figure that out shortly.
Let's just get um double eps.
And here we'll get double ups.
And you literally have to add stuff in
like six different places. Very
annoying. I tried to figure out a way
around this, but like there are actual
CUDA compiler limitations
that uh make it very difficult. And if
you go look at like the solution that
PyTorch even has, it sucks
and it's really not a nice way to just
avoid all the spoiler plate.
Okay, so this is
an end toend version.
And you did not pass the weight back,
did you?
That is a problem.
There you go. It is my personal color
scheme. I made this.
This is the the whole config file.
There's not much in it.
I'm glad you appreciate it. I have
gotten many complaints about this color
scheme, but I like it
uh, this is not going to compile, but
we'll fix we'll fix some errors.
Yeah, I just put this here and forgot to
delete it.
Uh also I forgot to add a autograd
wrapper to this.
See, this is the part that I actually I
hate the most is the pietorch wrapper
binding shenanigans.
Like obviously the numeric are hell and
stuff, but like that's that's kind of
skill issue. Uh this is not skill issue.
This is just awful awful code and
nothing like literally impossible to
write anything better or not anything
better, but anything good.
What's the main reason? What
alternatives? Jacks, terrible.
Tiny grad, better jacks, but not what I
want.
Anything else? Non-existent.
Porch is also the one that everybody
expects you to have.
dude, I hate jacks. You do not have to
learn jacks for Majoko either. You know,
like you realize that you can just use
jacks with PyTorch training code, right?
You can keep the tensor on the GPU and
just turn the jacks tensor into a torch
tensor.
Deep mind sweeps. Well, deep mind suites
suck. So, like what's the point?
You're not going to be able to do
anything because like those deep mind
M's are so slow they're unusable. Oh
yeah, I guess they did make I forgot
they did the Jack's version of them.
Uh if you have to do control then I
guess.
But honestly Jack's training code is
just uh so bad.
It's like classic Google. We are very
clever. Let us show you how to build
things. They build something terrible.
No instance
in data. Yeah.
MJ warp.
I mean, that's still not a reason to use
it for training code, right?
I honestly think that the way to go for
training code is going to be it's going
to be closer to what I'm doing here,
which is just that we end up getting
ourselves a collection of kernels, like
fused kernels,
and we use those with basic torch code.
Like you'll be able to even use these
with the Python torch API if you want
and it'll still be way faster than
anything else.
Wouldn't warp be compat Yeah, Warp will
be compatible with Torch.
I mean, don't use it with Jax, right?
Like
I don't know what Tensor back end
they're going to ship it with or tensor
integrations, but like that [ __ ] should
not be hard. Well, shouldn't be.
Oh, well, it's going to be on the GPU,
dummy.
I'm just going to see if I can figure
out from this one small thing
I can just do torch.tensor of apps like
this.
What's this?
No suitable conversion from disgusting
C++ thing to disgusting other C++ thing
exists.
Fun
fun.
What are we doing today? We are Working
on some kernels in the CUDA mines.
There are several kernels that need to
exist and to be fast for Puffer Lib 4 to
be good. I am currently working on them.
It is hard
Where did my error?
Huh? Oh,
RMS.
And tomorrow I do not work on colonels.
Tomorrow I lift weights all day.
That'll be good.
I'm just going to lift weights and
weights and weights.
Uh, this actually built
fuel.
What the [ __ ]
Did I paste the wrong [ __ ]
Oh, I pasted the wrong thing, didn't I?
I'm confused. Did I paste the wrong
thing?
Perfect.
What's this?
What you find useful usually. The exact
setup that you see me using here is what
I use for everything.
Oh yeah, it's the imple.
Okay. So, it would just be like this.
So,
I guess we
I
hate this [ __ ]
We're going to have to really figure out
how to make like torch go away and not
suck so much.
the heck did this find?
Wait.
Well, I've officially managed to listen
to the same song so many times
that I've noticed some very small
background noise in it that you're not
supposed to notice. It has annoyed me.
how I have it.
This is how I have it.
Oh, module. Wait.
Yeah, like this.
Let's see.
That's annoying
company profit.
Yep.
we provide um
mostly it's off of custom sims. We do
some pryo service stuff. Um pretty soon
that's probably only going to be for
existing sim clients
or like new sim clients, whatever.
There's also like R&D and other things,
mostly Sims these days.
I really focus the vast majority of my
time on core research
and then we do like some business
and know I mean presumably right the
prices will just go up as Puffer gets to
be um more and more ahead of everything
else
like this update is was so much work but
it's going to make Puffer so fast.
I mean, kind of my goal this update was
like leave no stone unturned, really
aggressively optimize Perf, see how fast
things can be.
So weird.
This honestly feels way worse than the
Cuda because this is just like straight
[ __ ]
for now, I don't feel like dealing with
this. So, I'm going to do it this way.
Like honestly,
what the [ __ ] Pie torch.
Maybe it'd be a better library.
Okay. So there we can do RMS norm. All I
have to do is allocate the weight.
Yeah, this will be easier as well, won't
it?
I want to at least get some version of
this tonight.
plan to fire hire people. Uh I do on a
contractor basis.
Obviously only people who have like
demonstrated that they can handle
substantial RL projects in Puffer
though.
Okay, that looks like a legitimate mess
up on my part.
max diff. Nan
kill
lovely nand def.
out and norm
X.
Okay. So, what do we paralyze here? We
get batch times t total
right
grid size.
Okay.
Oh,
I think this is probably wrong, right?
Yeah, it's like this, right?
This other dim because it's Yeah, the
parallelization dim is the other one
index.
See about this.
It's like this.
This
I missed one thing.
I missed. Um
I had to wait on the wrong dim.
diff is 11. Okay, so we get a real
number now.
fell.
val times at RMS.
boom.
Correct. kernel for the for forward
Board signature has three inputs that
require gradients.
Wait, no. The Ford has three.
You got to return towards tens, sir.
Okay, so the colonel breaks,
but that's fine.
Yeah. So, this is completely wrong.
Uh,
Okay.
Where was my original? Um,
What? This is had a hard product. That
doesn't make sense.
Oh,
this is dot product. This is how to mod
product.
I see.
Okay.
So then you have to do for dotproduct
you have to do a loop over h
Yes, I need the
Okay, hang on. I know how to do this.
Tired.
I'm going to try to not let it mess with
it too much, but I need the indices. I'm
too tired to calculate the indices
manually.
[ __ ] I'm doing it myself. These
models are dumb as [ __ ]
Get B, T total, and H, right?
Just a percentage.
It's literally just a percentage. We
don't need any stupid models.
idx over h. No
idx percent h.
Okay.
And then the norm index.
Then from this math I should be able to
do it
So right.
This does not change.
This change.
No, it doesn't.
So then what I get to do.
Yeah, this would imply then that we have
to do
Yep.
Okay, we'll do it this way.
Brad
X
Wait.
H.
Oh,
it is
I think you want some of this,
but I actually think I had the loop
structure correct before.
Okay. So
now what
this base address
Isn't base just um
do percent?
base.
This is Yeah, this is it.
Let's just do grad
base
Storm index.
No.
Okay. Why is this not What's this uh
this error real quick?
Make a little bit more progress and be
done.
one should be very easy now?
Just be this.
Oh,
get Yeah.
This is actually a very tricky colonel.
I'm gonna have to finish this tomorrow.
But yeah, there's some tricky stuff
here, guys.
It's like I sit down to write what I
figure is going to be a very basic
kernel because it's like a threeline
operation and it turns out it's a very
very freaking complicated kernel.
Wouldn't you know it.
This is why autograd exists.
Too bad it is slow.
Maybe this one I shouldn't have done
like this. I don't know.
But the way that Torch has their
kernels, they're very, very hard to just
like use and build on.
Anyways,
well, we'll get this finished at some
point soon. Um,
it really just feels like this is a hole
you can pour unlimited time into.
And I think we'll do we'll do this one.
We'll see from there. Uh, I got to get
some rest. So, for folks who have been
watching, thank you for tuning in. I
will be back live tomorrow. No,
tomorrow's Sunday. tomorrow. I lift
weights all day. I will be back live on
Monday.
Um,
if you're interested in my stuff,
everything's live. Puffer.ai
and watch agents playing in your
browser. These are live RL agents like
you can. This is me playing taking over.
This is me with my pants off now that
can actually play correctly again. Uh,
the puffer star helps me a lot. Is it
cold in your gym? Absolutely.
Join Discord if you want to get
involved. Other than that, follow me on
X.
We are doing quite well on here lately.
Almost 25K and all the educational stuff
is on here as well.